[Alkış]
Merhaba selam
Vay bak güzel
konuşmalarda çok kötüyüm
buraya konuşmacı olarak çağırdığımda
Trex de tedex karşıtı gibi konuşma
yapabilir miyim diye sordum Tabii
ileride bana istediğinizi söylemekte
özgürsünüz
gelince ben de vazgeçtim hevesimle
karıştır
ıyoruz sonra zaten
benim şahsen saçma bulduğum şeyin
organizasyonla değil de bazı
konuşmacılarla alakalı olduğunu fark
ettim
saçma bulduğum şeyde şu
insanlara Hayal satmak ama bunu böyle
çok popüler size karışabilir yani işte
hisse gerçek olsun asla kaplansın
yaparsın
oğlum sen var ya harikasın inanılmazsın
evrenin sahibisin
evrenin sahibi değiliz Hatta onun
kayıtsız kaldığı
aciz ve şımarık bir misafiriz ve
küpten her şey bizden önce de vardı
bizden sonra da var olmaya devam edecek
ve bütün bunları olan etkimiz
düşündüğümüzden daha az olacak
galiba
Ve yine işte bu
popüler'den başarı saltanatın
hikayesinde ki burada da benzerlik gibi
hissediyorum ve
işte böyle başardım şöyle Zengin oldum
Tamam zenginsin bir sürü param var da o
kadar parayla Ne yapıyorsun ki
Yani aynı derinliksiz vizyonsuz hayatına
devam ediyorsun
ya da Mesela adamın babasının 50 tane
Apartmanı var
çıkıp anlatıyorum ben işte şöyle Zengin
oldum
Sen emek bile vermedin ki sen sadece
şanslı bir spermiyorsun doğru zamanda
doğru yerde doğdum
ve tamamen şansla alakalı bir şey
aslında kaldı ki zaten tek başarı kısası
maddi olarak sahip olduğu
zaman ondan koşarak uzaklaşmak gerekiyor
Dolayısıyla
birinin nasıl başardın hikayesini
dinlemek yerine nasıl baktım hikayesini
dinlemek bana daha ilgi çekici geliyor
yani sıkılıyorum başarı hikayelerinden
yapacak bir şey yok
çünkü
Aslında çoğumuzun başına gelecek olan
şey bu yani unumuzdan 9'u çuvallayacağız
ve hayat Aslında böyle bir şey
Dolayısıyla burada size gaz verecek
motivasyon konuşması yapmak yerine
başarısız olduğumuzda neyle
karşılaşabilirsiniz ve ne yapabilirsiniz
size söylemek bana da dürüstçe geliyor
da samimi geliyor ki bu açıdan spor
felsefesinin Bana bayağı faydası oldu
Store felsefesi Antik Yunanda ortaya
çıkan bir düşünce biçim bir stoeing
acıya dayanıklı demek
özetle söyledikleri şey de şu hani biz
hep İyiyi başarıyı Hayal ediyoruz ya
onlar da diyor ki kendini her zaman en
kötü olasılıklara hazırla ki
çuvalladığında o kadar da üzülmeyesin
gibi bir mottoları var yeni yıl
kutlamalarında
bir tane dayıyla röportaj yapıyorlar
işte belli bir sene olmuş falan adam da
şey diyor Çok şükür kötü günleri geride
bıraktık sırada daha kötü günler var bu
adam viral oldu falan hatta bu
açıklamasını şimdi o bölgeyi Biz
gülümseme ile
acıyı o kabulü ile bir şey çok güzel bir
yer
karanlıkta kahkaha gibi
böyle güzel bir ters psikoloji vardı
özetle
acıyı ve yürüdüde yaşamak başarısızlığı
da kabullenmek Çünkü oradan da
öğreneceğimiz çok şey var bunu
deneyimlemin önemini anlatıyor falan
Dolayısıyla Aslında edebiyatın
edebiyatta da bunu görüyoruz yani
felsefenin anti kahramanları gibi
psikolojikler edebiyattaki antik
Kahramanlar da böyle şöyle düşünmenizi
isterim edebiyat tarihinde Türk olmuş
gerçekten klasikleşmiş Kahramanlar Böyle
şeyler yakışır ve Erdem bir akıllı Cesur
süper kahramanlar değil antik
kahramanlar
işte ne bileyim raskornikovo düşündüm
Gregor samsayı düşünün
Selim ışıkla tutunamayanlarda
Joker var holden var Çavdar tarlasında
çocuklar bunlar hep böyle huysuz Uyumsuz
karakterler ama acı da olsa bize gerçeği
bir tek onlar söylüyor
ve edebiyat Tam da zaten bu işe yarıyor
yani
insan ruhundaki çatlakları çelişkileri
zaafları en kötü çocuk duygularımızı
bize onlardan öğreniyoruz antik
kahramanlar
isteselerdi bize gaz verip bizi motive
ederlerdi ve biz onlarla daha mutlu
olurduk ama onlar bizi kendimizle
yüzleştirmeyi tercih etmiş kişiler
bir de şöyle bir şey var yani
dedim ya başarı ben çok sıkılıyorum diye
mesela raskolik
tatil olmasına rağmen dünyada en sevilen
Roman karakteri olmasını bir sebebi var
Çünkü dosya eski böyle acımasız bir
dürüstlükle İnsan Denen Muamma ya o
büyük soru işareti ne
bir ışık tutuyor Bir ayna tutuyor ve
kara Ayna tutuyor Daha doğrusu ve bize
böyle bir otopsi masasına yatırıp
inceliyor
şimdi
başarı hikayesi biraz komik düşünüyorum
raskombi kavuz Böyle her sabah 5'de
uyandırıp koşuya çıkarsak
dönüşte böyle cebinde kalan o klasik son
Rublesi ile bir kadeh bir şey içirtmek
yerine ne gibi böyle Cuma falan Gelirsek
ne hikaye çıkarken
böyle birine sadece annesi sever
Amerika'da yaşayan bir adamdı işte
sürekli At yarışlarını izlemeye gidiyor
bahis yapıyor hipodrum'a gidiyor Falan
şimdi gel bu adamı vegan yap mesela Uzun
Yaşasın diyelim Amerikan şiirine da
büyük bir darbe vuramazsınız
zaten
uzun yaşamı merakını da biraz saçma
oluyordu
ne yapacaksın ki arzu ettiğin şey
sevdiğin ve tanıdığın herkesi görmek
gibi yani yüz yaşında ve tek başına çok
Sıkılacaksın
Dolayısıyla Önemli olan şey bana uzun
değil de güzel yaşamak gibi geliyor
Geçenlerde şeyi izledim GittiGidiyor
musun
20 yaşında 30 yaşında tekrar
gitmeyeceksin ki 80 ile 90'a uzatacaksın
yaşımı
Bu da ne kadar hoşuna gider bilmiyorum
abi bana
bana çok ilginç gelmiyor yani
Bir de ben yeni tanıştım birini
Neden böyle daha 5 dakikasında bir
şekilde vegan olduğunu öğreniyorum ki o
da Tuhaf yani mesela bunu
böyle her yerde bir şekilde ifade etme
gereksinimi duymak bana bu işin hiç
felsefesini değil de etiketini sevmek
gibi geliyor
sonra da şeye başlıyor Aa sen hala
etmiyorsun Ne kadar cahilsin
bana niye bağırıyorsun ki Ne bileyim
yani iklim zirvelerine özel zevkleriyle
gelen insanların sözlerini
bolluk için değil de her gün et balık
yumurta veriyor
[Müzik]
Son zamanlarda böyle birkaç şeylerle
karşılaştık fark ediyor
[Müzik]
bir de şöyle bir Klişe sekmesi var ondan
da bahsetmek isterim
ferrarisini satan bilge koca bir yalan
arkadaşlar Çünkü o adam size Bilge
değilse pazar değil ferrarisini satıp
Lamborghini aldım
ve
yapılan bütün romantik doğal
güzellemelerini ve saçma buluyorum Çünkü
gerçekçi değil Çünkü Doğa öyle bir şey
değil
Doğa bağımsız ve tekinsizdir
varoluşu insana adammamıştır
onunla uyum sağlaması gereken insandır
Doğa dediğimiz şeyi yazlığındaki 15
metrekareden balkonda bahçıvanda
algılayamazsın
ona gerçekten kulak verenler
öyle Her gördüğü çiçeğin rengine
kokusuna şiir yazanlar değil
dedim Depreme dayanıklı ev yapanlar
mesela
yangınlara karşı önlem alan insanlar
doğayı gerçekten önemseyen insanlar
bunlar
o gerçekliği kabul etmek gerekiyor
Çünkü Bu yüzeysel romantik güzellemeler
yüzünden bir sürü beyaz yakalı köye
Göçtü ve hepsinin hüsrana uğradı birçok
arkadaşım var
köye taşıyorlar işte çoğu alkolik ve
daha da depresyondur daha da kötü
olaylar yani
yani sönmeye çalıştığım şey
kendimizi iyi tanımalı ve çevremizi
doğru algılamalıyız ki hayaller ve
Hayatlar arasındaki uçurum çoğalmasın o
söyleyeceğime de daha uzun süre kalmıyor
Dolayısıyla bazı kavramların iğneden
sorgulanması gerektiğini düşünüyorum
Evet başka var aslında kaç dakika
[Müzik]
Aslında bunun karşılıklı soru cevap
olmasını isterdim
ama herhalde böyle yapacağız
hala buradasınız ve bana bakıyorsunuz
kendi başarı hikayemden de bahsettim
[Müzik]
30 yaşındayım yazarım Normalde yapmam
gereken şey oturup kitap yazmak ama son
birkaç yıldır YouTube'da bir kitap
programı yapıyorum
Bu da hem konuşmamda hem görülmemi
gerektiren bir çok Bayılmadım ama ilginç
bir şekilde hoşuma gitti kitap
programının ilk bölümünde ilk söylediğim
şey burada kimseye ihtiyaç duymadığı bir
şey yapacağım Edebiyattan ve felsefeden
bahsedeceğim oldu
ihtiyaç varmış herhalde 2-3 yıldır yani
Bayağı uzun sürdü
Dün hayatımdaki en güzel yanımda oldu
aslında
Ama bu benim başarım mı ebedi değil
bence bu izleyicinin başarısı Çünkü bana
tahmin etmek çok zor bunu kız arkadaşımı
sormadım size
Dolayısıyla
benim hikayemde bu kadar asla basit
Bir de bir de bir alıntı yapacağım
şiirin Metin altı oktanmış şehir bu çok
kısa çok Öz
O da şöyle diyor sen ki sen ki banarsın
altın suyuna Yıllardır bir Ziynet gibi
kendini bırak lağım karışsın bundan
sonra kuyruğuna biraz da pislikle sana
erdemini
O çok hoş Ama
şeyi Tamam bakmakla
teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]